what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to top
21
men keeping their wives and girlfriends
in line the return of men part 4. before
i start
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification
bell while you're at it follow my
instagram it's just pearly things
with a z not an s with a z
and go follow me on there because i have
some cool like fitness and live content
okay i'm getting ready to go sounds so
bad now
does it oh it's bad it's gonna cost you
two grand at least to fix not to mention
your brake pads are completely bold
i've got something else that's
completely bald you're tires
yeah i saw that i think you can ride
those puppies out for another 10 000
miles
i bet you've got something i could ride
for 10 000 miles
nope the shop does not provide
transportation while working on your
vehicle you can contact your insurance
provider though don't get you a vehicle
[Music]
my husband only allows me to be around
him with a full face of makeup so i wake
up before him
apply my makeup and get back into bed
before he wakes up
wearing a dress to breakfast every
morning is an absolute must
he likes to drink 12 ounces of orange
juice but an 8 ounce glass guys this is
clearly sarcastic
i make sure to fill it up after every
sip he also hates touching strawberries
so i feed them to him
one by one he's also really into fitness
so i go change into those amazon
leggings and only do squats while he
watches
he hates sitting in a cold car seat so i
make sure to sit in his car for 30
minutes to make sure his seat is at his
desired
temperature
[Music]
such a dick
why is he so cute
eating animals is wrong gordon ramsay
hurting animals that's wrong
gordon ramsay share this song
and if you call me a donut that's fine
vegan doughnuts
so guys i'm going to give you uh some
relationship advice
always keep a picture of your
significant other as your
wallpaper in case you're having a bad
day you can always look at it
say at least i'm not at home with her
that's funny
let me show you what you're missing a
pair of [ __ ] pads
hey everybody this is kylie jensen she
cheated on me no i didn't
hey guys this is the cheater do you hear
how voice raises
half the time it's fake though
[Music]
[Music]
oh dear that's just not necessary story
time
so this past christmas i bought a
neighborhood kid a new bike
this kid is in the fifth grade going
into the sixth grade
he told me like 200 times see this kid
uses his bike
to run his own lawn mowing business he
has his own trailer that he built by
himself and everything
so one day i saw him walking down the
street with his lawnmower and he didn't
have his bike with him i say man where's
your bike
and he told me it got stolen i said well
hey man maybe good luck and for
christmas you'll get a new one
then i thought well i have an old bike
laying around maybe i'll just give it to
him but i better go ask his parents
first
and when i got there i met his
grandmother and she told me how his
mother recently committed suicide and
that
she know how to take care of him and
while she's not broke by any means a new
bike just wasn't in the cars this year
seeing that she ended up take custody of
him
now within 30 minutes i'm at the bike
shop i tell the clerks what i'm doing so
they really
really hooked me up give me the best
bike locks and everything i even gave
him one of the trackers that's on my
motorcycle in my trailer
so it won't get stolen again when i gave
it to him i told him that i appreciate
how he always works so hard and takes
care of his grandma
and now as much as i tell him not to he
won't quit cutting my grass
oh come here
high five
oh
oh dear
why did you park that far away
do you see all those empty spots
why did you park out here oh my gosh my
boyfriend
he always says this to me too
it's just easier to park by itself and
then no one can touch your car
is full of women
[Music]
[Applause]
yes i'm taking wifey resumes i know it's
controversial
so this way if there's a sister out
there who think i need to know who she
is
she got the opportunity to make herself
known that's all that means
sending that wifey resume cover letter
and photo with the resume
okay that means your political and your
personal
how you make a good wife but how you
make a good
fellow pan-africanist i want to see the
best of both worlds
i want to see the best of both worlds
the cooking and the
consciousness no snow bunnies it is
not that type of party must be natural
hair everything on you got to be natural
if the hair fake if the breasts fake if
the nails fake
if the eyebrows is fake don't send a
resume
and you must be open to plural marriage
because there will be two of you king
kong
doubles up on everything
you baby
[Music]
thank you oh this is so cute
here baby
thank you so much
[Music]
she looks like she's a good ass cook
oh wow
so organized
oh wow oh my gosh all this food looks
amazing it looks like restaurant quality
wow
i gotta learn how to cook man
all right this might be the car
this might be the beauty
that was a good one did i be good that
was a good one
justin yeah nice to meet you man cody
happy birthday happy birthday i don't
need a ride home
no it is all part of the plan i'm doing
my good deed for the month
[Music]
not the way that i do love you
[Music]
let me come home
i that's so cute oh my goodness
that's adorable this mission is
definitely blown literally so
cute um okay i actually really enjoyed
or i enjoy those videos because you
always see like
men doing all this stuff for women but i
think it's really important for like
you know treat him like a king and he'll
treat you like a queen so
let me know in the comments if you guys
agree or you disagree do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification bell and i will talk to you
guys
next time